[Music]
that's going to win an oscar
um
can i slap somebody now please
and then the director will just [ __ ]
slap
i have baldness can i when do i get to
beat the [ __ ] out of someone i mean you
know it's just
that's i that's a very political
statement but it is
actually i would say will smith has
appeared in loads and loads of sci-fi
movies so we could probably like talk
about this
um i thought it was staged
and now it looks like no
no
well you know i knew at one stage when i
heard the microphone hit
yeah you know because you because i i
got a hold of like the the uh unedited
version that they didn't you know the
raw feed
and you know you see
chris rocks the shock wave goes across
his face and you hear the
on the microphone and
that was an impact
yeah he did catch him but he slapped him
like such a will smith is a big fella he
really should be able to knock yeah
chris rock skinny little fella on his
ass if you know you know after the slap
you also um he had his arm in
his uh this this arm here in a defensive
uh posture because you because you know
will smith has taken a lot loads of uh
martial arts classes for whatever movies
he had his arm you know kind of in a
defensive posture after he just gave uh
chris rock the hollywood bit slap i mean
it was
it was only when he then sat down and
went keep my wife's name out of your
mouth then i thought oh it's not staged
said it twice
yeah it's a big childish girl i mean
that's that's hard i just thought it was
bad and then i was reading all about
their relationship i'm like
you didn't make marriage
he didn't mind keeping someone else's
private parts out of her mouth just that
wouldn't just be
household morality is on something like
monopoly
okay who asked us guru next
i would like to now apologize
and i'm not saying that jada pink smith
is go on him
i think she looks right now walt
disney's in jail
yeah she looks evil i'm pretty sure if
jade plinkett smith told me give me all
your money and then look to me i just
would
you just got evil eyes man i'll just be
like whatever you want look just get out
of my jesus
um but yeah
anyway the views of my resident american
friend are his own and they don't
necessarily reflect the views of this
channel
no matter how much jay is giggling about
it
[Music]
[Music]
you